so
matt gates is under federal
investigation for
playing some role in sex trafficking and
potentially having a relationship with a
17 year old girl
congressman thanks so much for coming on
appreciate it um
so this is obviously a serious
allegation
tell us what the truth is from your
perspective
it is a horrible allegation and it is a
lie the new york times is running a
story that i
have traveled with a 17 year old woman
and that is verifiably false people can
look at my travel records and see
that that is not the case what is
happening is horrible
against me we have a lot to talk about
[Music]
have a seat right there please
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
traveled
[Music]
i'm not the only person on screen right
now who's been falsely accused of mature
research
you were accused of something that you
did not do and so you know what this
feels like
i can say that actually you and i went
to dinner about two years ago your wife
was there
i brought a friend of mine you'll
[Music]
remember
[Music]
falsely accused
[Music]
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample
trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song
please do it
[Music]
big massive dumps
[Music]
big massive dumps gums dumps dumps
[Music]
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election
which is just
[Music]
big massive dump you turn the faucet on
in areas where there's tremendous
amounts of water where the water
rushes out to sea people are flushing
toilets 10 times
15 times as opposed to once
gums
[Music]
what is going on here what is going what
is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost them the election
what is going on here what is going what
is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost them the election
what is going on here what is going on
[Music]
all right welcome everybody we're
standing by for joe biden who's going to
be holding a press conference taking
press questions not only from american
press but also for oh my on hold on
oh i am not only from um american press
but also
south korean journalists this will be a
joint press conference with president
moon jae-in
uh of the republic of korea known to us
as
south korea and that is going to be
very soon but i'm glad to have some time
with everybody here
because we have so much to talk about
and i appreciate everybody who's here
watching
we're going to get to super chats we're
going to get to all sorts of things i
know we have a bit of a mic
issue there is a situation happening
around me right now it's going to be
resolved
really soon really really soon i i
promise you guys it's going to be
resolved and we're going to be in good
shape
from the standpoint of audio but just
dealing with a bit of a background noise
thing um no
need to continue talking about it unless
you really want to and i think people
probably do
but uh yeah there's uh there's elements
of cleaning that are going on right now
i am not i know some people might have
tuned in for drama today
i don't at this point the drama has
branched fractally to the point where i
can't even keep it up because originally
there was drama
because i didn't talk about the israelis
israeli-palestinian conflict
then there was drama because i did and
then
um various streamers were
concatenating criticisms of me and then
now there are all sorts of others like
i'm getting pinged with google alerts
from all sorts of youtubers that are now
jumping in because they smell
blood in the water and this is the thing
and i used to do this i'm not attacking
this i'm just saying
it's now for me beyond where i can tell
you everybody who's mad
when i had a much smaller youtube
channel 20 000 subscribers even 100 200
000 subscribers i would look for larger
channels
and then i would attack uh because i
would try to get them to react and all
of that stuff but the problem is that
there's now so many like i did a thing
and then stephen kenneth destiny bonnell
the second did a reaction video
chris bosh did and um uh who else you
know there was a few of these
now other people are seeing them and
they're doing even like lower brow
criticisms and so it's it's sort of like
the saudi royal family where now there's
12
000 people in it because with every
generation everybody's having kids and
kids and kids and that you just can't
afford it all
it's a really similar situation i can
know i know there are other clips people
are sending me oh
so and so did a clip you know uh
steve from montana has now criticized
you and
uh decentralized union is now doing a
clip and all of this different stuff
i can't keep up with it i can't keep up
with it i have become the very thing i
swore to destroy that's exactly right i
like that comment
so if people you know via super chat or
something send me something
specific i guess i'd look at it but i
don't have anything
um planned really right now as far as
that goes yeah i just don't care
exactly i just don't care i can keep
track of my followers not the haters
that's exactly the way i would say it um
unknown prodigy by the way checking in
with today's first super chat says
fractal branching exactly that's the new
term fractal branching
um okay where did i want to start today
because there are a few i have no unban
requests so we're skipping that all
together
um i do have some oh okay let me just
thank everybody via twitch bibo butt has
subscribed
and battlestar catalactica is here
neptune at the nine month mark
what else do we have jazlyn knights has
gifted a sub that's four
covert catalyst is five t sis
is six the almighty kevin is number
seven
a grove is number eight small fuzzy moss
is number nine word fencer ten
and i think that's it oh savvy lady is
number 11. appreciate that guys thanks
for kicking us off
um okay let me see i have my notes here
oh yeah i mean i guess this is probably
similar
to the um brief commentary about now
the the fractally branching attack
content which we're not going to get to
we've had to ban so many people lately
it's real but there has been an influx
of trolls
where we have had to ban people on the
subreddit
we've had to do twitch bands youtube
bands
it's i would i would probably put it in
the hundreds over the last
week and you know i spoke to big time
chess streamer levy rosman not long ago
and he gets
way more people watching his streams
than i do he only bans a couple of
people a day
and i think it's the the nature of the
content
patrick says a cup of sauce at
chick-fil-a is one ounce
oh okay yeah i covered this chick-fil-a
story where a bunch of republicans are
blaming joe biden
because the number of sauces is being
limited at chick-fil-a and they think
somehow it's biden's fault
and chick-fil-a announced we will only
give one cup of sauce per item to people
and i was like
who needs that much stuff i've i've
never been to a chick-fil-a but it's
like is the food that bad that you need
a cup of sauce
on each item and this user patriker is
saying a cup is only an ounce
um anyway i don't know i don't know
anything about
chick-fil-a i've never been to one i
apologize
so we've got that and then oh if you
guys would allow me i would like to do
just a really brief tech check-in
because there when i whenever i ask for
tech help on streams
it is 99 trash replies but it's one
percent
solutions to my problem so here's my new
uh request for you guys with travel
starting back up
i am going to be doing some remote
broadcasting this summer so i will be
going to my remote setup and here's the
thing about my remote setup
it is painfully inefficient it's too big
and i what i need to do is physically
shrink down the size of my mobile setup
so i would love your help in helping me
figure out how to do that okay so right
now this is what
my setup looks like i've got my evre20
which plugs into a cloud lifter the
cloud lifters are tiny i've got one
right here
it's just it's just it's little right
so my cloud mic goes into cloud lifter
cloud lifter goes into my voice
processor dbx this thing is gigantic
it's really not practical to travel with
that i also have the mic
on a big mic arm which is great when i'm
driving somewhere but not when i'm
flying so that's all my audio
that plugs into my sony x70 camera which
is pretty sizable
and then i've got a light that goes on
the shoe and the tripod
that's a lot that's a lot i then have to
bring my green screen
although for a couple of locations this
summer i'm going to basically just
order a green screen and have it sent to
where i'm going to be
this entire signal flow of audio into
video goes into my blackmagic
shuttle i'm replacing this with an
elgato version which is about a third of
the size
and then all of that goes into my laptop
so it's like what could i shrink
obviously i can get rid of the mic
arm and do a desktop stand but the
desktop stand the whole point of the mic
arm is if i tap my desktop
this mic arm doesn't pick it up i could
get a physically smaller microphone
i don't know if it'll sound as good if
someone can recommend
like a love lav lob
a lavalier mic that would really sound
as good as this i would switch to that
but
you know okay the voice processor can i
go without it all together i don't know
this does a lot to get rid of room tone
and so on
the camera i could definitely have a
smaller camera i think if i had a
smaller camera i could have a tiny
tripod
i could just go with like a really small
tripod or even like a suction cup mount
if the camera was smaller lighting i
don't know
so i think that there's there's some
opportunities here
to reduce i would love to be able to put
everything in a backpack
other than the green screen i can just
get a green screen wherever i'm going
i'm not so worried about that
so that's the question if people have
and really you know if you're gonna be
like
oh just just use your phone only come on
guys
yeah i'm going to do the entire show
with a phone and not no professional
video or microphone or
you know going it needs to go into obs
you know all this different stuff
um info davidpakman.com
okay that's my request so we've gotten
the tech questions out of the way
i do want to say thanks to sean wells
sean
just signed up i mean just now at uh
joinedpakman.com and his new member
number 12 today thanks a lot
i do appreciate that i also want to say
thank you to jazlyn knights for gifting
a sub on twitch
megan solo for gifting a sub
elusive joe that's
three via twitch putting us at 15.
appreciate that very much no that's the
the rackmount voice processor
i don't need it i just need to know what
do i replace it with
because i could be in a room with a lot
of background noise
the noise gate makes it so that we
eliminate that
um that's the question all right so
definitely if we have tech savvy people
you know if they're going to email me
and say david do it all with an xbox
just save it you don't need to email me
thanks to sin pre for the twitch sub
let's look at some super chats stephen
kenneth is very well informed on audio
video related things he may have some
space-saving tips for you
not a bad idea have you ever thought
about getting a bunch of akai
controllers and turn your setup into a
more sophisticated recording studio
i have never thought of that now
deepak based in omnipilled what does
that mean
what's your position on the death
penalty in relation to percentage of
innocents executed i am against the
death penalty
period i am against the death penalty
period
um and br says fricken david you can't
please everyone's crying i i understand
i get it all right let's get
into some clips this is very aggressive
cnn reporter bianna golodriga
was going to uh oh and i see people
recommending the blue yeti
i have three blue yetis it's not up to
par it's just not the quality is not
what i need
remember i'm recording an audio podcast
i get that the blue yeti is okay for
streaming
but we we need a higher fidelity
microphone the
i have i have more blue yetis than i
know what to do with but that's not
suitable for my uh and by the way that's
not even smaller than this so i'm not
even saving
i i i lose everything and i gain nothing
with the blue yeti
uh okay so biannual rodrigo was
set to interview the pakistani foreign
minister
and he just opens with anti-semitic
slurs it's super aggressive let's take a
look
okay and this is somehow muted let's
unmute
let's go to the beginning much to
discuss today u.n general assembly
gathered today to discuss this crisis
pakistan's foreign minister shah mahmud
qureshi took to the podium to demand aid
to be allowed into gaza
and called for an end to quote israeli
aggression
a just solution for palestine is
imperative
for the maintenance of regional and
global peace and security
clearly the onus for restoring
peace rests on israel
and the pakistani foreign minister joins
me now from new york mr minister thank
you so much for joining us um it has
been a very busy day
from your end do you hear any talks
about a possible ceasefire coming
anytime soon now remember this was like
before the ceasefire that we got
announced yesterday
i am convinced the tide is turning
i am convinced the public pressure
the pressure of public opinion is
mounting
and sees fire is inevitable
israel is losing out they're losing the
media
war despite their connections
they are losing the media war the tide
is done are
deep buckets what does that mean
well they're very influential people i
mean they control media
i mean
oh man i'm pretty sure bianco rodriguez
jewish
um he would be banned from the twitch
chat let's put it that way yeah
let's let's continue and i i would call
that an anti-semitic remark
well you see the point is uh they
have a lot of influence and
they get a lot of coverage now what has
balanced that
is the citizen journalist
who has uh who has been reporting
uh sharing video clips and that oh my
god all right so we'll do a full review
not exactly subtle guys not exactly that
would be a perma-ban
on my uh on my channel yeah
a little bit it was a little bit
suspicious when he dropped
a an overt anti-semitic trope um
all right so that's the foreign minister
of pakistan and we'll cover that
we'll cover that on monday um
[Music]
other super chats coming in sandra says
i wanted to wait until memorial day to
join since i've wanted to for the
longest but since i caught you live i'll
go ahead and subscribe
for the shout out absolutely sandra
let's do it
no better day than today um
okay so we've gotten that out of the way
i have a dave rubin clip that came to my
attention this one's almost a little bit
sad
you know there's this thing about dave
rubin let me see if i can actually find
this just because
otherwise i know people are going to
there's sometimes i'm pulling up the
data because i want to i need to bring
receipts hold on
compare group and report
okay there's some people believe that
dave rubin's youtube channel
is really really influential and just
a gigantic youtube channel because he
gets all these speaking gigs and jordan
peterson and all this stuff
what you have to remember about the
reuben channel this is compared to my
channel right
in in blue as you can see there's no
question dave rubin
is is killing it with subscribers
although he's leveling off and we're
really closing that gap especially in
the last couple of months as you can see
here
um and in fact we may be let me see
projections
yeah we're projected to surpass reuben's
channel actually okay not until 2023 but
maybe we can accelerate
accelerate that but here's what you have
to remember look at the views ruben
report is in blue
okay the reuben report really doesn't
get a lot of views
a lot of their content is like in
partnership with different organizations
which means he's getting paid for it and
that's totally fine we do some of that
stuff too
but the subscriber numbers have gotten
totally out of hand with views and in
fact
if you look at the daily views this is
going back to
i mean i don't know this is going back
to 13 months ago we're in red
on basically every single day we're
crushing reuben on views and that's
really what matters it's not close guys
like on average we're just shy of a
million views a day
and reuben's shy of 200 000 so from the
standpoint
of views we're five times bigger than
reuben
i would never have the audacity to go on
the air
and say how dare a guest i want
not respond to me and not show up i'm
big and
important like i would have to be i
don't even know if there's substances on
earth that would
put me in such a delusional and entitled
position where i would do that
and we're five times as big as ruben
from the standpoint of views
okay check out the entitlement here
reuben upset that he can't get
caitlyn jenner on his show oh and that
does remind me of one other thing that i
want to say before
we end the show today so bitter look at
this which is that
you know as you guys know i've sort of
in these last two three weeks sort of
supported
i say supported yeah i've i've said nice
things and
somewhat promoted uh caitlyn jenner who
is running
against gavin newsom in this california
recall election we have repeatedly
repeatedly on this show reached out to
all the proper channels
to her team we haven't heard back i've
tweeted at her many times
we we net we have five times the views
of reuben and we
every week we don't hear back from from
guests and sometimes they're guests that
i like
it's not like a personal thing you know
my tweets get
way more traffic than any of her tweets
do so i know that either she
or the intern who's running the twitter
account or the team are seeing it
yeah so it is my belief at this point
that this will sort of be my last effort
at this that if we don't at least hear
back the fact that nobody is responding
to us
you don't have to do the show you can
just politely you know say no we're not
doing it right
we're figuring out the media stuff or
whatever it's a palpable insecurity
that's exactly right
that's exactly right it is my belief at
this point that the the caitlyn jenner
thing is a complete
sham what you know and what's funny is
like
not responding to ruben is separate from
caitlyn jenner's positions on issues
if dave rubin really is a fan of caitlyn
jenner's policy platform which isn't
completely non-existent by the way it
was like rake the forest do forest
management and
make sure all the private plane owners
stay you would think that if
if dave rubin believes caitlyn jenner is
great for california
then it wouldn't really matter if
caitlyn jenner responds to ruben it
would just be the right candidate i
don't think it's real i think they put
together a nice
slick ad and i'm guessing she has a
reality show team with her
i don't know that for a fact so that's
speculation unsubstantiated
but i would love to know if that's true
because i'm guessing it is but i don't
believe it's a real
campaign which is a damn shame because
california needed somebody
to stand up and in an odd way it could
be a real campaign but they just don't
care to respond to dave rubin you know
that's a possibility
it's conceivable that that's the case
maybe it was supposed to be like the guy
who is currently president joe biden
he clearly ran a real campaign because
he won my guess is he would not have
responded to dave rubin
it's not really you know someone like
kalyn jenner to kind of flip this whole
thing on its head
i don't mean to make this about me
specifically but the point is it's just
it's own that's all that this is about
he doesn't mean to but it just happens
to be all that this is about
i've been one of the most outspoken
people in in california i have a pretty
big platform here
to get the voice out and if your team is
so inept that they guys
he gets 190 000 views a day
like okay i mean what what are you
talking and how many of those are in
california
they just don't respond we've tried on
on every proper
front behind the scenes and i've done it
publicly
the fact that you guys don't even
respond either this is an unserious
campaign and you're just using it
for pr purposes for a new reality show
or something like that or you're
completely mismanaged
so i say that with no animosity i say
that with no hate you can tell guys from
the tone of his voice
there's no animosity at all or malice or
anything else
i guess we'll give it another day or two
for someone to just respond
he's putting a 48-hour ultimatum on it
and um
you don't have to do the show obviously
caitlyn if you think i'm you know too
much of a hard interview because that's
what i'm really known as
you know i really beat my so oh my god
it's just pathetic really really it's
like you i almost start to feel bad
where it's like dude maybe
maybe look inward maybe maybe therapy
you know i mean there's like there's a
lot going on there i would love to talk
to dave
he's he has not responded to me let me
see
when is the last time we had any
exchanges
he um he cut me off i mean you guys know
the story i'm not i'm not saying
he he just stopped responding to me
last time i heard from him was what date
is this
november of 2017. wow so it's been
almost almost four years yeah
um anytime i would love to talk to him i
would love to talk to him
so that's the latest with dave rubin um
i mean is he serious if he's not
responding to me i five time i have a
pretty big following here on youtube
five times the size of his i don't know
is he serious because he's not
responding to me i sound like an idiot
if i say that
okay sandra woodruff has just signed up
at joinedpakman.com and jazlyn loves
david has just signed up at
joinpakman.com really appreciate that
we have really really strong traffic
right now
actually to join pacman.com also want to
say thanks to adam david lee for the
seven months subscribed on twitch
link diablo has subscribed via twitch
it's future man thanks for the five
months
that is three putting us at 21 and if
you're just joining us we are
really close to hearing from joe biden
and the south korean president moon
jae-in they will be doing a press
conference they will be taking questions
etc deretend says
jenner going on ruben's show creates a
grift vortex it may create a black hole
california may collapse on itself that's
a good point
daniel says did you see ruben trying to
make the point that the left hates
gamers
reminded me of seinfeld's the jews hate
grass
always have i didn't see that i didn't
see that
um aviator says i know a lot of people
are tired of big massive dumps but i
still giggle every time i hear it it's
on another level
yeah michael is suggesting i get a
neumann
tlm-102 let's see what that is
neumann tlm-102
what kind of a mic is that
that is a no that's a large microphone
that's
that's that's two-thirds the size of the
one i have i
i have microphones for my rode studio i
would only change if i could get one
that's
significantly smaller and
almost as good but i don't i don't need
another i have four of these things
hanging around here
reuben is hilariously butthurt yeah i
don't like that term but her
is it's so it's a homophobic term it's
not a term i use i think we can say
um we can say other things we can say
other things
so i'm not um that's not that's not for
me all right
um here's a funny thread you guys tell
me if this is true
i genuinely don't know if this is for
real look at this zachary patrizo
who is the staff writer at salon so not
satire as far as i know check this out
mike pillow ce i'm sorry my my pillow
ceo mike lindell
is now claiming he has not only obtained
both dominion and smartmatic voting
machines
but also has hidden the machines in
secret locations across the country
it's like geocaching according to a mike
lindell assistant who just spoke with
salon the pillow maven
is currently flying somewhere now and is
unable to comment on the matter
according to public information i can
confirm that lindell is now aboard his
private jet which took off from new
bedford
mass and appears to be heading west at
this time uncle
unclear if he is traveling with a voting
machine
lindell made a very quick stop at elmira
corning airport in horse heads new york
and is now on his way back to bedford
remains unclear
if a machine is hiding in horse heads
and why it was such a fast trip
what a bizarre situation
i don't i don't even like it's sort of a
speaks for it's presented without
comment type of situation
um all right so that's the latest with
mike lindell we might have more
information about that
by monday um oh okay we covered this
already
oh whoa this is funny so this oan
reporter channel ryan
she got an exclusive interview with
trump
and it's look at the introduction look
at the
level of sucking up here check out this
introduction and check out just every
and
her opener to trump is how biden's not
even legitimate look at this this is
crazy
president donald j trump left an
indelible mark on u.s politics
from the 25th floor of his iconic new
york headquarters
one america news sat down with our 45th
president
for an exclusive one-on-one discussion
there
he shared with us his forecast his fears
and his hopes for america's horizon
in the process we witness an
illuminating snapshot into the mind of a
man
whose leadership in battles sparked a
movement
that forever altered the course of
american history they're acting like
trump is
you know fdr or something it
this is an oan exclusive interview from
new york city new york
mr president we sit here in trump tower
many days and many miles
from what many americans consider an
illegitimate biden white house
oh man so anyway i i have not been able
to find more clips of that but if people
know who
if anybody published a bunch of clips or
that of that or if someone has the full
interview
info davidpakman.com good sirs please
email that to me i would like to take a
look at that
um okay so we've gotten the channel ryan
interview
out of the way and then lastly
oh yeah check this out so this is fox
news
host uh steve douchey n that's not this
guy but you're going to see a moment
this guy multiple times he
misstates the number of covid deaths in
the united states now the real number in
the u.s
is six hundred and three thousand for
some reason steve douchey thinks that
it's fifty two thousand
and then like he's like and you know
thirty three thousand of them are in new
york
and it like doesn't eat new york city
and it doesn't compute like wait a
second
sixty percent of all coveted deaths are
just in new york city
none of it makes any sense look at this
and and he
it's not even clear to me whether he
realizes he's making no sense
think about it this way folks here in
the united states of america 52
000 americans have died from covet 52
and then this did you guys notice this
other guy goes um
what do you how does no one react to the
fact that that's obviously the wrong
number
look at this united states of america 52
000 americans have died from covet 52
000 i was shocked to see that 33 000 of
them
actually lived here in new york city
what i don't know look this is look at
his he
he was very surprised i was surprised to
hear these numbers and then it keeps
getting worse look at this
which is shocking uh this is the moment
where i think
hold on right this is the moment where
someone might be off screen saying what
you're saying is crazy
um let's see that in real time again
i just i'm i'm imagining in my mind that
someone off to the side is like
here in new york city which is shocking
uh two million americans have been
impacted so
two million americans have been impacted
well let's see
33 million people have had the virus
somehow
only 2 million have been impacted
this is insane this is a guy who's been
covering the pandemic for
14 months did i hear that right he said
oh my god
he says two million have been in how do
you get that
33 million people have had it here
in new york city which is shocking uh
two million americans have been impacted
so
what how did it come
to infect the entire planet
now they cut to this guy and i don't
know if this guy is like what on earth
earth is ducey talking douchey ducey
peter ducey steve ducey
um what on earth is he talking about so
i i
let me just watch it once more in total
it is unbelievable think about it this
way folks
here in the united states of america 52
000 americans have died from
covet 52 000 i i was shocked to see that
33
000 of them actually lived here in new
york city which is shocking
uh 2 million americans have been
impacted so how did
it come to infect the entire
planet right and what's funny is that
you know all of this is just a lead up
to like a lab leak conspiracy
because the title down here is
investigating the origins of covet 19.
so you know where this
is going unbelievable why how
uh and by the way if the number if the
dramatically
falsely low numbers he gave are shocking
what would he think if he saw the real
numbers right
like if he's shocked that 52 000 people
died and 2 million were affected
what would he think if he learned that
603 000 people died
and 33 million plus all of their
families
were affected um
it's all weird it's all very very weird
um okay people are telling me
what what am i missing about this
people they're mad what did i do wrong
guys
i see people in twitch chat furious with
me
i don't even know what's going on okay
uh let's continue other super chat's
coming in
shouldn't chanel be channel be
interviewing him on his golden toilet
all the better to appreciate the massive
dumps yeah not a bad idea
the etymology of butt hurt comes from
spanking it doesn't have homophobic
origins but instead child abuse origins
oh all right well i don't like it anyway
maybe you should copy news max's budget
setup yeah
um does anyone really think mike pillow
quit stimulants
i don't know i don't know
that's a great question though um okay
let me say thank you to a few more
people
user give me your milk please has been
subscribed for 10 months via twitch
prime
also want to say thanks to kyoko for the
twitch subscription
bjorndragon has subscribed alice has
subscribed
and it's future man has subscribed that
puts us at 26
and then just as a reminder um
grab one of those memberships at
joinpacman.com if you want to know
more about the award-winning bonus show
the best way to do it is to get such a
subscription
at joinpacman.com and i will thank you
live on stream if you do that we do have
a discount code it's completely immoral
it's so
cheap that our lawyer accountant
um a group yoga instructor
peloton coach and all of our staff say
don't do it but we're offering it and
that code is immoral 21.
the code immoral 21 chops like i think
it's in
i don't even want to say i think it's
like 70 uh
off the cost of a membership and i'll
thank every single person who uses it i
don't even care i thank everybody who
signs up
and of course remember if you have
amazon prime
make sure you are signed up to one
channel for free via twitch prime this
is five dollars
amazon gives you if you don't use it it
stays in jeff bezos's pocket
none of us want that okay so remember
link amazon to twitch give it to someone
right
even if you give it to chris vosh or
mike from jersey
or the eggman or stephen kenneth destiny
bonnell ii
or whoever just make sure you're not
leaving the money with bezos that's
important and on that note
darth bane has just re-upped their
twitch sub
for 22 months
in a row 22 months in a row
unbelievable also thanks to j.r dubs
as well as keccarone pizza
who have signed up putting us at 29.
22 months yeah that's like five years
right that's a long time
it's a really long time all right let me
get to some voicemails
um let's see what i've got what do i
have today
um david okay i'm just
glancing at what i have
okay here's a co someone works with a
coveted denier let's see
hey david um i was just speaking with a
co-worker earlier this afternoon
and basically he was uh making the
allegation that
covet is no different than ammonia and
that's
been ammonia within the past
um 12 years so since 2007 there have
been
uh cases of uh ammonia
um he's saying ammonia right
building and building do you think this
is a false equivalency
yeah i covet and ammonia are two
different things totally different
yep no he's definitely wrong that's a
false equivalency
um okay question about ufos
hi dave this is steve in san diego and i
am calling you
out on your lack of coverage of the
biggest story in the history of humanity
ufos or uaps are real
where is your coverage where is your
commentary
this is the biggest story ever man you
are asleep at the wheel if you're not on
it okay
so 60 minutes new york times
yeah i've already commented on the the
60 minute story
um all right let's see what else we've
got
i think i know who this is
hi david this is ashley again um
so i was just talking to some people and
i noticed that some people here like
don't understand that
um there's people that are protecting
them
and it's like how how do you
like is the only work that somebody does
religious
knowing that there's other people in the
world who don't share the same religion
and knowing that they're overweight and
there's some people in the world who are
starving
how do these people not think that like
pretty pretty prescient yeah
somebody's not gonna hurt them right
like they go through their day
every day like where they're so racist
and they surround themselves with other
racist people
who only treat them nicely we're never
rude to them
you know and they just live in their own
little bubble where
they're protected and they don't
understand how anybody could
feel differently about them you know
because nobody's ever treated them badly
they've never been scared for their
lives um
and they'll just say stuff like you know
well
nobody fights for our country and
everything like that
there you go like like they're just
there
and nobody's protecting them and this is
just how we get to live
right this is how the world is letting
us live i mean it's like the most
ignorant thing i've ever heard in my
life that
um you can be
completely freaking useless and have
people want you to live
yeah no she's making a lot of sense i
know exactly what she means and that's
really well said and i really couldn't
have said it better myself that's that
that absolutely makes sense
okay let's move on
what else uh
there's a lot here
i'm just look i'm pre-screening by
looking through the transcripts
um steve from columbia
oh here's a clip about me capitalizing
on the youtube twitch drama let's take a
listen
to that hey what's up david so i was
just watching your stream today
and i saw you kind of going over all the
drama
and i'm only like five or so minutes
into you playing clips and stuff
but you were talking this i've got it
cranked up as loud as it goes this guy's
just really quiet
about how you could really capitalize on
it if you were good at drama
and i just wanted to say that you know i
really respect you
being the objective commentator that you
are
um i really come to you for most of my
news honestly because i
nine times out of ten i'm getting a very
very unbiased
take you really when when you talk about
and explain things you explain it very
well
and come from it from you you say what's
right and what's the right move but you
also
tell us what's realistic and you don't
go too far wonky
left okay all right it's very very low
so i think he
he likes that i don't do the drama stuff
okay that's fair that i think that
that's a
that's a fair point um
okay let's see what else
seeing if i have anything else
interesting for you guys
um my
that may sort of be it oh here's one
more
here's more philosophy with ashley hold
on
oh um about the uh
what were you saying about the uh
statutory raped
i felt like in high school a lot of
girls were getting
raised and stuff like that and i don't
necessarily think
that it's very conducive to educational
atmosphere to be telling your peers
about this kind of stuff
like i really think you should go to a
professional because after the third
time somebody
told me that somebody raped them what is
she talking about
people girls were getting grants grants
to do what
just walked up to the guy and i kicked
him in the [ __ ] nuts until he pissed
blood
okay whoa okay
we're moving off of that one um
we're moving off of that one geez holy
[ __ ] this is
this is crazy all right let's just keep
moving
um
here's an unknown caller with transcript
not available this is sort of like
roulette
let's listen
oh it seems like it's just literally a
silent voicemail okay that's why there's
no transcript
that makes sense uh all right good so
we've gotten that let me see if i have
anything else here
caller from lakeland florida every
caller we've ever had from lakeland is
completely off the wall
i anybody want to listen to caller from
lakeland i don't think this is bob from
lakeland
yeah let's see because lakeland is a
here we go let's see
hello david my name is keno hicks i live
in lakeland florida
for 50 years i'm 72 years old for 50
years i was a republican and now
switched over to the green party
and i aspire to be a spokesman for the
green party
i already like this i'm already liking
this florida man
and in this infrastructure i'm watching
it's
friday uh uh 21st of may
and i'm watching your program night
right now on free speech tv
i know some people are disappointed that
this guy sounds normal but i like it
11 30 in the morning
in infrastructure there there's a woman
naomi prinz m-o-m-i
last name p-r-i-n-s she was on book tv
two or three years ago she's written a
book of how there should be an
infrastructure bank
in the united states where citizens
regular citizens can buy
stocks from it or bond from it and
instead of corporations running it and
money can be funneled into
infrastructure especially we need a high
speed train
spokesperson for the green party i
advocate
high speed it's funny because he started
the voicemail by saying he would like to
become a spokesperson for the green
party and now i think he's saying as a
spokesperson for the green party he must
have gotten hired during the voicemail
train system be put in place as soon as
possible
but please consider having her as a
person to interview all right in her
book at least talk about her book
and the idea of so the green party
please be a spokesperson for me
keno hicks in lakeland florida as a
spokesperson for the green party calling
for an infrastructure bank
love it as outlined by nomi prims
so there will be other things too i will
ask
that call me at area code eight six oh
okay and then we're not going to do
we're not going to do that okay
um oh he called back a couple times but
i think we're not going to go to that
all right
that's interesting that's not
interesting that i mean that's that's
not bad
not a crazy person from lakeland florida
and let me see if i have anything else
oh he called back with his genesis story
he actually gives his genesis story
listen to this this seems interesting
hello david this is kino hicks once
again i don't want to be a nuisance but
i got a lot of information to share
my new name will be the bamboo beatnik
there you go the bamboo beatnick and we
don't even have to come up with a
nickname now we've got one
my mother's uh it was in the american
indians i
appear to be a white body but my mother
side of the family were american indians
and then american indians you could
choose a new name when you had a new
chapter any time in your life when a new
chapter was beginning
so me being in the green party now i
used to be painted buffalo
but i must a shaman had to shape shift
and so i'm going to convert into a plan
i've got to interview this guy
this is a guy i have to interview now i
think this is a guy
who's who needs an hour probably on the
show
this could be our riley martin from the
howard stern show
shampoo and now i'm going to be the
bamboo beatniks
so hope we can
make good music together and making this
a better world
bye he's going to need a prime time
special yep that's a new that's a genius
caller
that's good okay so we've got that see
look at what we're coming across here
and then let me just there's only a
couple left um
[Music]
let's see what else i've got
something about anti-aging vitamins one
more from
ashley which i we had to get away from
the last one but let's just see
um i just wanted to call about um in
response to
deprogram and trumpus i liked your um
method of using like sound and stuff to
kind of like
spin off of the excitement or whatnot or
like the vibe that
um american trump is have like i think
that
um like competing with him somehow
like musically like promoting concerts
or something or something rock and roll
something that's like not really um
like that relevant to him but like maybe
more relevant to his supporters
this is about deprogramming trumpists
right something that's like more
beneficial
and optimistic i think i think those
different those things
um definitely something optimistic
because
um it's just kind of like a
soul sucking power and i think that
what these people need is to know their
own strengths
and abilities and um
that maybe there's something that inside
of them that's
you know unique i don't know what's
going on so i'm going to move on
um and then just five more to look at
someone doesn't want the garden being
shown listen to this someone's angry
about the garden
david why
are you showing us the garden so much
right please stop and i otherwise i love
the show
see this is what makes this is what
makes it tough about doing a show
no you i show a garden people love it
and then someone calls in and they're
like do not show that garden anymore
there's no
there's no there's nothing so there's
nothing
that would be too trivial or too
inoffensive someone will call in and be
mad about it even if most people like it
okay um here's a caller about the
chick-fil-a sauces
i'm interested in this because i don't
i've never been to a chick-fil-a and i
want to understand
what's going on at chick-fil-a with
these sauces let's listen
hey david was just listening to the show
caught the segment about the uh
chick-fil-a with the sauces
that's great they're blaming biden for
the the
lack of sauces the shortage of sauce
anyway uh i've been to chick-fil-a let's
know they do have a damn good sandwich i
don't uh
they don't have the best sandwich the
best sandwich is the popeye's chicken
sandwich
is that true i've never been to popeyes
either
that's it that's a question for probably
someone who's been to both
if you got a pop out of you i'd
definitely recommend the popeyes chicken
sandwich
but chick-fil-a does have decent foods i
don't know i'm like you i don't know
what
the need is for all the sauces maybe a
little ketchup for your fries
or something or a little mayonnaise for
your for your chicken sandwich but i
don't get it
anyway i just thought it was funny all
right
all right let me see if i can find like
chick-fil-a menu what does chick-fil-a
even have now i'm not gonna go
obviously because of the entire
homophobic stuff and also i don't even
know where there is one i just can't
imagine even finding
one of these locations but let's see
chick-fil-a chicken biscuit chick-fil-a
chicken minis
an egg white grill
uh hash brown scrambled burrito
hash brown scrambled bowl oh hold on
people can't see everything there it is
um bacon egg and cheese biscuit
sausage egg and cheese what's the most
calorically dense item here the burrito
700 cows that's pretty strong
sausage egg and cheese bacon egg and
cheese sausage egg cheese muffin
a buttered biscuit an english muffin
hash browns
greek yogurt parfait fruit cup
okay now these seem to be the the sort
of signature dishes
chick-fil-a chicken sandwich chick-fil-a
deluxe which looks like
it has a slice of tomato and a slice of
lettuce and cheese is the difference
spicy chicken spicy deluxe grilled
chicken
chick-fil-a grilled chicken club
chick-fil-a nuggets grilled nuggets that
you see these grill lines right here
read michael pollan's books and you will
learn how much science goes into those
grill lines it is an entire world of
science
chick-fil-a chicken strips okay
chick-fil-a cool wrap is this the
throwaway for
like is this the throwaway healthy item
that they have on the menu
okay then they've got some salads a
market salad
waffle fries fruit cup side salad
mac and cheese chicken noodle soup kale
crunch i would not think to go to a to
go to a
chick-fil-a and get a chicken noodle
soup
greek yogurt parfait waffle potatoes
buddy fruits applesauce
ooh the applesauce looks alright i'm not
gonna not gonna lie
nuggets kids meal okay this doesn't seem
that interesting i don't know maybe i
i know i haven't been to a fast food
place in 20 years
maybe i just don't get it anymore
gallon beverages i would get one of
those maybe just for visual
visual comedy and the five pound bag of
ice
it would be funny to go there and only
get a bunch of bags of ice
all right so let's see what the infamous
is this considered a cup right here like
are one of these considered a cup
barbecue sauce chick-fil-a sauce let's
see what's in it
soybean oil god i love soybean oil the
top ingredients are soybean oil
sugar barbecue sauce which itself
is tomato paste and corn syrup oh my god
spices water mustard mustard seed
turmeric distilled vinegar egg yolk
man this is wild now i remember why i
haven't been to any of these places for
a long time
um okay all right let me see what other
sauces garden herb
honey mustard and you can get honey
roasted barb honey roasted barbecue
sauce polynesian sauce
oh that's interesting the polynesian
sauce instead of being mostly soybean
oil with some sugar
is mostly sugar with some soybean oil
and corn syrup wow this is wild
so like where's the flavoring i guess
it's just
it's the natural flavor which they don't
even it's not even broken down further
this is joe biden's america can you guys
imagine tragedy
all right so that's chick-fil-a just
just to be thorough
let's look at the popeyes menu
i've also not been to popeyes
okay um family feasts chicken sandwich
signature chicken
hand-crafted tenders family meals
seafood beverages and desserts
let's look at signature chicken
two-piece chicken meal
three-piece chicken meal four-piece
chicken meal two thousand calories
holy [ __ ] um
16 piece okay
i mean to be totally frank i'd probably
go if i had to choose one of these i'm
probably going to pop eyes maybe we need
a poll
i don't know but uh if like i had no
choice
i'm probably going to popeye's that's my
instinct from looking at that
people are furious okay all right let me
say thank you to dan martinez who just
signed up at joinedpakman.com
anna picharillo just signed up at
joinpakman.com
and axel resendez just signed up
at joinpackman.com thanks to both
to all three of you and then i also want
to say thank you to some people who
signed up via twitch including thomas
the promise
duke boy x ash g-width
c-a-w
hold on that's one two three four five
kilodactyl is number six
um yeah
six and 32 puts us at 38. love it
love it okay
um very good
let's look at some other super chats
that are coming in as we wait for joe
biden here
dereten says u.s food labeling is a joke
spices cheers bro yeah i know
fade away says david pakman world famous
culinary elitist
you know it's that i don't think that
that's what it is there's people who are
like oh david a lot of people can't
afford
let me give you guys some examples um
hold on olive garden menu
with prices i'm gonna make a point right
here
okay here's two places
okay olive garden and an
actual italian place that when i lived
in this neighborhood in new york
i would go to all the time okay let's
compare prices
and i think maybe people will be
surprised maybe they will not be
surprised i don't know
um no and you can't let's see if i can
do
new york city olive garden
menu prices
here we go okay so these are relatively
close to each other
let's look at the menu and see whether
there's actually
whether this is a price thing okay
classic entrees at
olive garden chicken alfredo
24. chicken and shrimp carbonara 27
chicken parmigiana 24.
the tour of italy 27 dollars okay good
now this is a place that i used to love
when i was in this neighborhood in new
york city il corallo trattoria in uh
it's not too far i mean it's not in the
same neighborhood as
as that uh as that olive garden let's
look at the menu now this is
this is elitist it's too expensive and
okay let's take a look at the prices
rigatoni 12. wow
vegetable farfalle 12.
spaghetti giuseppe 12
so it's half the price now
it's probably fewer calories i mean look
at that you know 1 500
1400 calories 1600 calories
it's probably fewer calories but it's
half the price
it's half the price so i i never bought
into i think
it's more of a cultural issue then it is
a financial issue
because very often these places are not
cheap
oh people were saying that's lunch hold
on okay all right let's let's look at
the dinner
a lot that's lunch specials okay fine
fine let's look at veggie pastas
okay 15 dolla it's no yeah it's not that
different 15
13 13 these are now full entree dinner
prices fourteen dollars thirteen dollars
i'm telling you guys it's uh i don't
understand why anyone goes to olive
garden
when you have this this is one of my
favorite spots from the neighborhood
and it's quite literally half the prices
okay all right thank you very much let's
move on
we're getting off of it and that's new
york city that's exactly right
that's exactly right all right let's get
off of this please
mike says david we need you to break
your moratorium on fast food eating and
just spend an entire show eating and
evaluating fast food items i
i i see no opportunity to do that
edward says before i stopped eating
chicken the popeye's chicken sandwich
was my way to go
was my go-to so good too good drive
through line around the block love the
content deepak thanks for your work
appreciate it thank you very much thank
you very much oh and by the way
okay you know just to get back
what happened there that was weird
people saying but at olive garden you
get a limit unlimited breadsticks
ill corrallo gives you unlimited bread
as well i mean i don't know how much
you're really gonna have but i've been
there
uh i've been there and you know with a
few people they refill the bread three
times it's like how much bread are you
really going to eat
you know uh all right
thank you let's get back to where we
were
which was just looking at a few last
super chat um voicemails
oh there's people calling in during the
stream trying to get on
like this guy let's listen to this
hi david i don't know if you can hear me
on this one or if it will
give a transcript this time i think mine
was the silent one my phone's a little
broken
um what i was saying though is you
should
definitely i don't know if you covered
it or not but show the clip of senator
or sorry
representative tim ryan we did uh
tearing into the republicans yesterday
yep we did we would
you we we aired that yep that was that
was a good clip and tim ryan's been a
guest on this program and he's
uh he's he's an all-around um all-around
good guy
okay um next thing i'm going to do i had
a couple of weeks ago maybe i had
a request to review a particular wacky
interview from years ago to see what i
thought of it and we looked at the
charles butler
interview okay i had a request to do
that again i'm going to give you guys
two choices
between um
oh no not this two choices between
inner old interviews that we're going to
review
let me take a look here whoa
okay where were these playlists
oh no playlist doesn't seem to be here
oh man the playlist isn't here oh okay
that's that's not gonna work then
okay is there a particular wacky old
interview
that you think would be the top
candidate to review and this can include
any of the wacky ones it could be
any one of the ones with the westboro
baptist church or
brian fisher or um
some of the gamergate wackiness or i
don't even know
i i would review any old interview if
people want
let's see if i can even get that
playlist
jessie lee peterson
oh you know what might be funny actually
the first time
i was on jessie lee peterson's show
because people have seen the new one
but there's actually an older one let's
see two two years ago
four years ago oh yeah i don't even
remember this one let's check this out
okay this will be interesting i have not
seen this in a really long time a lot of
you remember the uh
dirty women march that happened the day
after
president trump's inauguration
where you have struggled with dirty
women like madonna and
others she dreamed
or thought of blowing up the white house
and
they had this judge this woman well i
mean jack's last name judge
who it sounded like she was on uh pcp or
something
actually she was on drugs it was uh
but it brought out the dirty women of
america
some people were saying that that was
sponsored by george soros and others
and that people were being paid to be
there
i have with me david pakman host
and exactly the producer of the national
syndicated david
pacman show a radio show with a popular
podcast and youtube it's already good
and david said you know he just agreed
with that he wrote an article
um with the huffington post
trump is bamboozled by alternative facts
he says dirty women mart he didn't call
it dirty but i do
dirty women march protesters were not
paid by george soros and others
and i'm skyping with david david good
morning sir thank you for coming on
thank you yeah i mean i'm curious you
know ad hominems atta
aside like dirty women that doesn't even
make sense to engage on that but
when you say some people are saying that
the protesters were paid i mean i'd like
to hear what people are saying that
specifically who is saying that when you
hear some of the conservative leadership
and conservative media saying that they
were paid
uh to to our protest i i do know that
they but who who is that i do know that
there are times when
protesters are paid to meet i used to
work for a union at one time
and i used to at one time help organize
the protest
this is great because i this is so long
ago i have no memory of how it went down
yes
conservatives or or businesses
and so i do know how they operate but it
has been said
how do you know that they were not paid
jesse this i'm
i'm having a hard time believing we're
even having this conversation on your
program because
so far what you've said is how do i know
the protesters weren't paid because
people would say they were not
you worked on years ago according to you
would pay protesters this is like if i
say
hey donald trump is beating melania
every every night
and you say to me well how do you know
that and i say
can you disprove that donald trump is
beating melania every night i mean
you're asking me to to defend something
which is the default in other words if
you're making the extraordinary claim
that protesters have been paid
provide some evidence you haven't even
named anybody in your article you write
women march protesters when you said
women but we they call themselves nasty
women
and so i don't know what's the
difference between dirty women and nasty
but uh you say that they were not paid
since you wrote this and you're here to
talk about this
how do you know that they were paid this
is
what we call burden of proof jesse and i
would assume that that you know this as
someone who's been in this world for a
long time
if i make an assertion that is an
assertion that is not supported by fact
it is incumbent upon me to provide
evidence and
again you've presented no evidence that
anyone was paid
other than saying some protests
you at some point worked on paid people
allegedly
and that there are some people who you
will not name
that say people were paid that's not
evidence it's not unusual nowadays i
remember when
ferguson and all those radical liberals
came out the children of the lie and
they protested
and for people who are wondering what he
he keeps coughing and hitting he has a
cough button there
that's what he's doing later they did
not get paid
so they start protesting against the
votes
who have promised to pay them that they
had not
gotten paid remember the black lives
matter the radical black lives matter
group and those votes
i don't know i want to bully ferguson
were protesting against those who said
that they didn't get paid i mean i just
don't
whatever i don't understand what you
just said has nothing to do with the
women's march
it just again if you can present any
evidence that protesters were paid at
the women's march
of january 21st i would love to hear it
i want to move on because
you have no evidence i mean i thought
you had no evidence right so you're
admitting you have no idea
i thought you had evidence that they
were not paid apparently you don't
uh let me ask evidence that something
didn't happen isn't that the best
that's actually really common in a lot
oh look at this still still image
it's actually really common that they're
like
give me evidence that x did not happen
well that only applies to certain types
of claims
last night last night
milo so there's no evidence there's no
okay we're moving on with no evidence
come down dave
last night milo was scheduled to speak
at uc berkeley
milo and the radical can we be happy
we're beyond that
children of the lie came out of the
woodwork and
and uh just created a riot
uh setting fire throwing rocks and
stones at the buildings and
attacking uh supporters of milo what do
you think about that
i'm against any violence of that kind
you know uh i think that uh i don't even
know why my opinion matters i mean i
i had nothing to do with that i'm
against starting fires smashing windows
and using smoke bombs which is what
uh what is he expecting me to say i'm
against the violence and the smoke bombs
but the fires i like
i'm reading people did i also though
think that
president trump is stepping in a very
dangerous direction by tweeting he
tweeted that
uh because milo didn't speak he
threatened to take away federal funding
from burke from uc berkeley
it was a law enforcement decision to get
milo out for his own safety so i think
trump should spend more time maybe
reading which it's not
clear he does much of and less time
watching fox news and tweeting a live
commentary because
whether or not this was a law
enforcement decision for milo's own
safety
the reason that president trump did that
because
uh in america today children or people
who are on the side of good
have been attacked and are being
attacked over the last eight years
because we had a
far left liberal socialist uh
anti-white anti-american president in
the white house yeah we didn't have that
there
was no more socialism under president
obama than under george w
bush i don't understand david
hold up trump tweeted threatening to
take away funding from uc berkeley
because there are people who don't want
to hear from milo i mean again
if anybody's going to be mad at at
somebody at uc berkeley
it should be with the police there
because it was their decision for milo's
safety that he not speak are you mad at
uc
berkeley police or who are you mad at uc
berkeley is against
free speech and because they receive
taxpayer dollars
they have a responsibility to protect
free speech
so you're saying that the police speech
that's a pretty strong anti-law
enforcement point of view for someone
like you to take david because it was
the police decision right
when when uh when you berkeley are not
protecting people like marlowe and
others
then the government has a right to
withhold
funding oh i thought that music was the
biden event oh my god oh it's music and
okay
thank god that donald trump is doing
that the greatest president on this side
of heaven
hold on hold on
oh my god
let's see him reintroduce me now
what a weird interview so i'm talking
i'm skyping with david patman
and he wrote an article for the in the
huffington post
trump is bamboozled by alternative facts
he says women's march protesters
were not paid and it's been written in
breitbart and other
media sources now remember of course
that there's two separate stories here
which was
did george soros at us at a at a sort of
organizational level
fund an organization that gave money to
black lives matter versus where
individual protesters paid and i'm sure
you guys in the audience know these are
two completely different questions
it's known that george soro soros and
others have
paid for these rallies and supported
these rallies and paid these votes
occupy wall street um
the um so-called mothers for the
movement
remember those black women who failed
their sons like trayvon martin and
others and now their sons are dead
and they want to blame it on so-called
racism
uh black lives mothers movement
black lives matter so it's it's it's
known that george soros and others are
people i like how he calls them sorrows
he's supposed to go out and be
destructive or
zorro do you guys remember zorro that
was an okay show
the woman's mart that dirty woman's
march
website had a huge list of partners
including planned parenthood
environmentalists feminists anti-gun
group
muslims occupy wall street radical
homosexuals and transgender what's funny
is
i had many critiques of the women's
march including that they said
jewish women weren't intersectional
enough to be in the leadership and all
of this other crazy stuff
and a lot of it quite anti-semitic but
he just goes down these very strange
paths
ewing is aacp
the national urban league i wanted to
ask were
were there any good and decent and
honest organizations that supported the
dirty mart
women's march listen jesse that's a sort
of bogus
question obviously you don't think that
those organizations are good and i'm not
going to be able to convince you that
they are i think here's the key point
the stories about george soros paying
protesters
i need you to answer that question for
me were there any good and decent
organizations supporting the dirty women
march
it's it's a silly question because the
organizations you listed
i think are good but you don't so where
where will that conversation get us
here's the main point you listed
breitbart etc
all of those allegations go back to an
article written
by azra nomani which appeared on the new
york times website
she was asked directly after breitbart
and all of the other right-wing news
sites said look soros paid them
do you think that these protesters were
paid to protest
the writer of the article said quote
i definitely do not conclude that the
people marching were paid to do so
full stop that's it and
and that says what to you let's just
interpret that for us david when the
writer said i cannot conclude the
protesters were paid
what did that mean to you when the
writer said that other personal opinion
and how do you know that that person is
telling you jesus
david the point is the person's opinion
david the point is you do not
david i don't want
who says she doesn't believe that the
protesters were paid so
by let me see if i can explain this by
citing breitbart
you're citing osra nomani who doesn't
think the protesters were paid
it's literally great but i feel like i'm
in the movie groundhog day here david
you're saying
david i'm turning your mic off you
cannot speak
over me
i can't hear you we're going to have a
uh i guess you're going bill o'reilly on
me there david
we need to have a comment session you
cast me and we're running out of time
and every time i'm running out of time
attempt to ask a question it's shocking
that there's a schedule to this insanity
it'll present something to you you just
run it off at the mouth
it doesn't work that's what it is your
skype configuration no it's not
it's not that we've not had that problem
any other time at any other time
um i want to know
what is your proof that but
first let me ask this because i wanted
to ask you about donald trump
did you did you vote for donald trump
you support president trump
what do you think i don't know i don't
want to assume that you're doing about
the
enduring march the women's journey march
rally did you support him
no i did not and why not oh there's
no policies of trump's my uh other than
some
very minor overlaps with bernie sanders
that that i agree with him on
and so you want to believe
that george because you're one of them
you want to believe that george soros
and others
did not support or paid protesters
at the dirty tomorrow rally you have no
proof at all that they were not paid but
yet you wrote an article saying that
they were not paid
jesse do you understand the difference
between
saying they weren't paid and saying
there's no evidence they were paid is
that a difference that you understand
yeah
i cited you so breitbart and others who
have said that they were paid
do you agree with that that uh the left
is more violent
and oppressive than the right no i don't
jesse hey why not
because there's no evidence to suggest
that so you have not seen the violence
and protest for an example
on the inauguration day on president
donald trump did he say foreign's apple
there were uh violence uh people were
setting
at least one car limousine he was set on
fire
uh there in washington dc and other
areas was that
did you see that violence i feel like
this is a clinic in logical fallacies
do you understand how did you see that
incident of violence
does not allow us to make any
generalizations about whether liberals
or conservatives have a higher or lower
tendency towards violence is that again
conceptually isn't good do you remember
do you remember when the
tea party rallies were happening
i generally remember you there there
were no violence
that's not true there was zero violence
no you had
you had the left objectively
conservatives are more violent because i
can point to
one incident of tea party violence i
would be committing the same logical
fallacy you're committed
you've had your time believing this is a
serious conversation
you had the children of the left coming
out and attacking
the tea party and pretending that
it was members of the tea party itself
just as we saw
during the campaign presidential
campaign
with president trump and hillary clinton
you had the children of the left
the children of the hold on la second
i think i just heard a test okay that
may be starting soon okay
going to president uh trump's rallies
and attacking the supporters but the
liber media reported it as though
hmm weird i guess that's part of this
recording oh
it was supporters of trump and you're in
denial about that
oh it's his music i i'm your mike's
cutting in and out of jesse i don't know
if there was a question in there
let me take a break back home
all right i think we can get away from
it i mean you guys kind of under he
doesn't kick me off i don't
well actually does he kick me off during
this show
oh that might be it yeah he doesn't he
he doesn't i guess that's just it let's
see what his commentary was
people on the right on the side of good
acting in that way so you're being just
artists
just what you're doing is intellectually
oh i'm on stage
on the right on the side of good which
allows you to take anyone on the right
who's violent and you say well
they're not on the side of good so they
don't count i mean these are
really sort of like amateurish um
distractions that you use david you're
not
just as you're not giving us any proof
that the dirty women
march protesting were not paid you not
being honest
in your discussion hey guys can you
prove to me that jesse didn't pay me to
be on the show
prove that he didn't pay right how do
you do that
now sorry jesse
you're not being honest about the um
the uh skype yeah situation a lot of
lies about skype
you have no problems happening there but
i appreciate you coming on you are a
typical little more
and we got what we expected from you i
think that we certainly got what we
expected from you that's for sure
misunderstanding of the burden and you
just you're just honest about the whole
dialogue thank you for coming on man
not dishonest prove me prove it thank
you david
um what do you think about it
it felt really shallow yeah i sure did
this kid by the way is a huge fan of
mine who was desperate to get a picture
when i should
it's so funny to see this kid pop up
first person
that i see when i go to jesse's studio
is this guy who wants pictures with me
oh my goodness let's finish this up that
it was just
he got hung up on this uh paid unpaid
and then he and then he's citing hate
crimes which are a total farce
because you're talking about the left
being more hateful and violent than the
right
and he cited hate crimes or something
and then he
cited people who are toting guns and
calling that violence
that didn't make any sense to me also i
noticed he didn't he didn't want to move
the conversation
forward right right
yeah he just wanted to stay with that
only
for whatever reason well he's a fax
type of a guy he likes to gather
information wow what an attack what a
brutal attack
and he didn't sound like he wanted to
get into why he supports
why he didn't support trump why he
didn't why he thought that those
organizations were good ladies and
gentlemen the president of the united
states
all right and perfectly timed korea
um let's hear from joe biden oh and by
the way thank you let's see who i can
thank real quick thanks to john cuppy
david ketchup just gifted five subs
dutchy fan is number seven twitch sub
jazlyn knight gifted another one number
eight
m gwinney number nine a lot of people
here i missed and i apologize
please please be seated
today i've been honored to uh to welcome
to the white house
president moon and i got an opportunity
to spend some
private time with him as well as with
our delegations
it's only the second person head of
state second head of state to visit
and uh the white house since i've been
president
and it's been a real joy it's a
reflection of how much we
value the 70-year alliance with the
republic of korea
and how essential we know the relations
is is to the united states
the future of the indo-pacific region
and quite frankly to the world
today has been particularly special
because this afternoon in addition to
our bilateral meetings
president moon participated in a
ceremony right in this room
that awarding the medal of honor to a
veteran
of the korean war a true american hero
colonel ralph puckett jr and i want to
thank you again mr president for joining
us
it was special i don't know that there's
ever been an
award of the medal of honor with the
head of state in the country where the
award was won
it meant a great deal to me and to the
family and to our country
and uh but today not only been an
affirmation of our shared history of
sacrifice
that binds the republic korea and north
and the north
excuse me and the united states together
well careful there's a commitment to
expanding cooperation i want to say
north korea
being our shared future in accordance
with our democratic values that have
made our nation strong
and agile and highly competitive in the
21st century economies
republic of korea and united states are
both nations built on
innovation and we must both meet the
challenges facing us today
and look to what is possible for
tomorrow
our partnership is grounded on our
ironclad commitment
to shared security our alliance has
long been the linchpin of peace security
prosperity and the region growing
more prominent and us being together
i was grateful that our two nations were
able to quickly conclude
a new cost-sharing agreement for forces
in korea in march which will benefit
both our peoples and i thank again
the president for that agreement today
we made important progress on a range of
issues
we spoke about the shared approach of
the democratic shared approach to the
democratic people's
republic in korea and
continuing threat of the dprk's nuclear
and missile programs
my team consulted closely with president
moon's team
throughout the process of our dprk
review
and we both are deeply concerned about
the situation
our two nations also share a willingness
to engage diplomatically
with the dprk to take pragmatic get
ready for right wingers to say biden's
going to war with north korea
ultimate goal of denuclearization of the
korean peninsula
today i affirm to president moon
that the united states will proceed in
close consultation with republic of
korea
and our strategy and our approach
and to help drive all these efforts i'm
pleased to announce
that ambassador song kim
a career diplomat and with deep policy
expertise will serve as the u.s special
envoy
for the dprk ambassador kim you're here
somewhere today stand up will you
thank you for being over there
[Applause]
there you go thank you for taking on
this important role we appreciate it
very much
the usrok partnership also extends
beyond the goals of the peninsula
the address they address issues of
regional and global concern
through stronger cooperation with
partners in the region including the
asean
the quad and trilateral cooperation
with japan the multilateral cooperation
is particularly important to coordinate
and approach
the situation that exists in burma as we
work to pressure the junta
to restore democracy for the people of
burma
and to address issues critical to
regional stability
such as maintaining freedom of
navigation in the south china sea
and preserving peace and stability
across the taiwan straits
today we also discussed ways that the
republic of korea and the united states
will work together
to address the challenges of our time
beginning with our efforts to end the
covet 19 pandemic
globally we agreed to establish a
comprehensive vaccine partnership
to expand the manufacture of vaccines
that have been approved
safe and effective and we can scale up
glow and
so we can scale up global vaccine
vaccine supplies
we'll strengthen our ability to fight
the pandemic and respond to future
biological threats
when it comes to fighting climate change
the republic of korea and the united
states are committed to making
ambitious 2030 targets aligned with the
effort to achieve
net zero greenhouse gas emissions no
later than 2050
and we're going to work together both to
mobilize climate finance for developing
countries
and to make sure that international
financing is aligned
to promote our climate goals we also
talked about
how to harness our nation's
technological advantages
to ensure the republic of korea and the
united states are cooperating
to shape to shape emerging technologies
around our shared value system this
includes everything from strengthening
our cyber security
to deepening our cooperation to build up
an open
secure g5 network
a 5g network i should say i'm talking
about the g5 it's another organization
uh-oh i'm thinking organization
that's going to be the top story on
hannity tonight 5g networks
and i'm particularly gratified that so
many leading south korean companies
see the benefits of investing in the
united states including this morning's
announcement
of more than 25 billion dollars in new
investments from samsung
hyundai sk and lg i understand the
executives those companies here would
you please stand up
[Applause]
thank you thank you thank you and i
think we'll do great work together
these new investments are going to
create thousands of good paying jobs and
jobs of the future
right here in the united states and
they're going to help fortify and secure
the supply chains for things
like semiconductors and electric
batteries
i know uh as i said that the ceos made
the effort not only to do this but to be
here today and again i thank them
for being here i thank you for making
the investments in our
future and yours finally i want to note
that yesterday i had the honor of
signing the law
the kova 19 hate crimes act to help
americans of
asian descent from having to live in
fear just walking down the streets
united states quite frankly i've been
ashamed
ashamed at the way some americans have
responded
it is shameful and uh there's a long
history trump is not going to like that
contributions of asian americans being
overlooked
forgotten and ignored and i affirm to
president moon today
what i said yesterday that we're
committing
and we're going to stay committed to
stopping the hatred
based on this bias i promise you
our people share a long history our
soldiers have fought
alongside one another our scientists
work side by side
in both our countries our students study
together
share ideas and see new opportunities
for future collaboration
and our people our people to people and
cultural connections are only growing
and k-pop fans are universal
now i can tell those who laugh know what
i'm talking about
[Laughter]
well anyway i'll get back to that later
the korean actress took home an oscar
for supporting actors this year
following up on the four oscar wins for
the movie
parasite last year and so our two
countries our two nations uh
uh have the tools and the deep
connections that we need to make even
stronger alliances and stronger
cooperation
and i want to thank you again for the
meetings today mr president
particularly our long private meeting i
appreciated that a great deal
and i'm looking forward to working
closely with you and your team
as we expand and strengthen our efforts
to shape
the future together and i mean that
literally to shape the future together
so thank you mr president
honorable president biden madam vice
president
i extend my deepest gratitude to you for
your special hospitality and welcome
today leaders and delegates of korea and
the united states
met each other's eye and had a dialogue
for the peoples of our two nations
this will give them hope for recovery
from coven 19
as well as a meaningful gift for
celebrating the 139th anniversary of our
diplomatic relations
president biden and i had an awarding
ceremony for the medal of honor to the
korean war veteran
one-on-one meeting as well as an
expanded summit
for many hours together we've had a very
frank dialogue like all friends
as regards the promotion of democracy
inclusive growth
the strengthening of the middle class
climate change response as well as many
other areas
two of us were able to see for ourselves
that we had common interests and
commitments
in particular we reaffirmed the strength
of the iraq u.s alliance and confirmed
the common vision for developing it into
an even stronger one
during my visit this time
the trust that has been built up between
president biden and i
will foster deeper friendship between
our two peoples
and lay a firm foundation that will
undergird the sustainable development
of the rock us alliance and i say this
with confidence
the most urgent common task that our two
countries must undertake
is achieving complete denuclearization
and permanent peace on the korean
peninsula
recently the biden administration
concluded its dprk policy review
building on past agreements including
the singapore joint statement
while taking a calibrated and practical
approach to seeking diplomacy with north
korea
is indeed a welcome direction of the
biden administration's north korea
policy
during the course of the review our two
countries closely coordinated with each
other in lockstep which i note with much
appreciation
moreover i welcome president biden's
appointment
of ambassador sung kim as special
representative for north korea policy
this reflects the firm commitment of the
u.s
for exploring diplomacy and its
readiness
for dialogue with north korea i have
high expectations all the more as such a
man of high caliber with expertise in
the korean peninsula issues has been
appointed
president biden and i discussed the
dialogues based on commitments
made between the two koreas and between
the u.s and north korea
are essential for making a peaceful
korean peninsula this is the
belief that we were able to reaffirm
moreover
president biden also expressed his
support for the inter-korean dialogue
and cooperation
under close cooperation with the u.s we
will work to facilitate
progress in inter-korean relations so as
to achieve a virtual cycle with usdprk
dialogue
moving forward as well korea and the
united states will continue close
communication
while exploring our north korea approach
through dialogue and diplomacy
on that i expect a positive response
from north korea
when strong security is firmly in place
we can preserve
and make peace two of us agreed
to further reinforce our combined
defense posture
and reaffirmed our commitment to a
conditions-based transition of wartime
operational control
it is also with pleasure that i
delivered the news on the termination of
the revised missile guidelines
the signing of rock u.s special measures
agreement on burden-sharing
in the early days of the biden
administration displays
for the world the robustness of our
alliance as a symbolic and practical
measure
today at the summit president biden and
i decided to expand our cooperation
in new emerging areas that will change
transformation
and landscape first to surmount kovi 19
our most urgent task
we pledge to pull our strength together
america's advanced technologies and
korea's production capabilities
will be married to establish a
comprehensive chorus
global vaccine partnership collaboration
between our two countries
will boost global vaccine supply and
contribute to accelerating
a complete ending of kovi 19.
through the global health security
agenda which aims to enhance infectious
disease response capability
multilateral cooperation will be pursued
as well
under this broad framework of vaccine
cooperation
illustrating the robust rock u.s
alliance an important announcement was
made
president biden pledged to supply
vaccines to korean servicemen
i thank you mr president this
announcement of the us i believe
extends the rock u.s alliance to the
field of health
in a meaningful matter second from
semiconductors ev batteries
pharmaceuticals to other cutting-edge
manufacturing technology
sectors in an effort to build secure
supply chains
we committed to work in closed concerts
digital of transformation is
accelerating and the areas of cutting
edge
emerging technologies are gaining
greater importance remember when trump
would do these and he wouldn't even put
the earpiece in he would just like
he just wouldn't understand he wouldn't
even listen it didn't matter cooperation
in civil space exploring
exploration 6g and green energy to
secure global competitiveness
furthermore to jointly advance into
overseas nuclear power plant markets
we decided to bolster our partnership
third in a bit
to address climate change we
will further solidify coordination
between our two countries
our two nations are already spearheading
global cooperation in climate change
response
last april the us hosted the leader
summit on climate
successfully korea for its part in next
week
is hosting pifuji's seoul summit once
again trying to build the international
community's collective will
for climate change response president
biden
will participate in the p40 cell summit
next week virtually
i welcome his participation which will
certainly help us catalyze the
international community
to come together president biden and i
participated
in the ceremony for awarding a medal of
honor to a korean war veteran
colonel ralph parkett jr based on the
rock
u.s alliance rooted in the noble
sacrifices of our heroes
our two nations will usher in a new
future
together without a doubt today's
meetings between president biden and
myself
and between the u.s and korea will mark
another milestone
for bilateral cooperation towards a new
era
president biden has extended such warm
hospitality and i expressed my deepest
gratitude once again
i look forward to our frequent
communication and continued close court
consultation last but not least
yesterday israel and hamas agreed on a
ceasefire
which is indeed a relief i appreciate
president biden's hard work and
leadership in this regard
thank you thank you
well first question i'm told is mary
alice parker
abc
thank you mr president i appreciate it
what is your
message to democrats who want you to be
more confrontational with israel and and
specifically to those that are saying
that there should be an
end to to arms sales i mean do you
recognize
that there's been a shift an evolution
in your party mr president
in the last 20 years on this issue
and i have a question for president moon
but i can wait to recognize that
there is no shift in my commitment
my commitment to the security of israel
period
no shift not at all but i tell you what
there is a shift in
the shift is that we have to we still
need a
two-state solution it is the only answer
the only answer and what i'm convinced
of is that we can now
move as i had did even before where i
was able to negotiate
well i should before the ceasefire was
negotiated
that i made it clear that i spoke with
president abbas
we were we're going to make sure that we
are going to provide for
security in the west bank and we renewed
this
can you believe that this question was
raised 45 seconds ago
someone's already been banned for
anti-semitism in the chat
it's it's really a problem left and
right in jerusalem
this intercommunal fighting that is by
extremes on both sides
it has to end it has to end and i'm
prepared to put together and are going
to attempt to put together
a major package with
other nations who share our view to
rebuild the homes and
without re-engaging without providing
hamas the opportunity to rebuild our
weapon systems
rebuild the uh the the gaza
re rebuild gaza and they need to help
and i'm committed to get that done and
so uh
i don't uh and i think that you know
my party still supports israel
let's get something straight here until
the region says unequivocally they
acknowledge the right
of israel to exist as an independent
jewish state
there will be no peace
can i ask a question to president moon i
am i'm curious if the two of you have
offered
any assurances uh behind the scenes to
taiwan and if president biden has
has pushed you to take a a
tougher stance when it comes to to
china's posture
towards taiwan
good luck
oh boy
well fortunately there
wasn't such pressure but
as for peace and stability
in taiwan straight we
agreed how important that region is
especially considering the special
characteristics between china and taiwan
we just decided to work more closely on
this matter going forward
so we have a question from a korean
journalist over here yes
uh two from the left
thank you for uh giving me this
opportunity i'm kang from yonah musian
news
um i have a question to both of the
presidents here as was mentioned by the
former uh
journalist i understand that the islam
israel and palestine
issues is very important but north
korea's nuclear issues is equally
important
on your to-do list what's the number uh
that's given to the north korean nuclear
issue on your priority list
mr president biden and also to mr
president moon in terms of your road map
for resolving
the nuclear issue in north korea
i want to understand whether your time
schedule actually matches and
is equal to one another in terms of
resolving the nuclear issues on the
korean peninsula
wow so to begin
under the new biden administration
the dprk policy
review has been completed in a rather
fast period of time
that means that the biden administration
puts a priority on its north korean
policy
among its diplomatic tasks and also
in terms of reviewing its dprk policy
there was a very
close coordination as well as
consultations between the united states
and the republic of korea
so the principle of the negotiations
towards north korea has already been
announced by the us government
a very calibrated practical gradual
step-by-step manner and very flexible
that is the approach that the current
administration is aiming to
adopt so that is the common
understanding that we have with the
united states
and we're going to continue to work
forward on this
and in terms of the timeline for the
denuclearization on the korean peninsula
there aren't any differences in terms of
how we think about this
no differences in terms of our opinions
i agree
with what the president just said our
goal is and remains complete
denuclearization of the korean peninsula
we want to make practical progress and
increase
uh security in the united states for the
united states and our allies
you know we closely studied uh what
others have tried
and uh what worked and what hasn't
worked and
you know under we're under no illusions
how difficult this is
none whatsoever and the past four
administrations have not achieved the
objective it's an incredibly
difficult objective as we move forward
we're going to stay very close
coordination with our friends and
our partners in the region including
president moon
and we fully recognize that this is
about
our collective security in the
indo-pacific region
and so but total denuclearization is our
objective
and remains so
all right well i get to the next
question huh
i like to ask the press a question
nancy corder cbs
okay thank you very much mr president i
have one question about north korea and
one question about
israel we've changed this one question
thing haven't we
two foreign policy questions uh you have
said in the past that you would not meet
with
kim jong-un the leader of north korea
without certain preconditions
yes what are those preconditions and
do you believe he would ever be able to
meet them
well what i never do is i never make a
judgment what a man or woman is going to
do or not do based on what they said
we'll see if he made any commitment and
i would
meet with him and if there was a
commitment on which we met
and the commitment has to be that
there's discussion about
his nuclear arsenal and if it's merely
and a means by which how do we
de-escalate
what they're doing um and so if that was
the case i would not
meet unless there was some outline made
and my
secretary of state and others would have
negotiated as to how
we would proceed but what i would not do
is i would not do what
had been done in the recent past i would
not give him
all that he's looking for is national
international recognition as legitimacy
and
uh the photo op give them what allowed
him to
move in the direction of appearing to be
more
how can i say it more serious about what
he wasn't at all serious about
i'd have to know specifics but the idea
of never meeting with
north korea i would make sure that uh
my team had met with his count their
counterparts
and i knew exactly what we were meeting
now
and then in the wake of all of your
conversations this week what is your
relationship
like now with israeli prime minister
benjamin
netanyahu do you have certain
expectations
that he will bolster the rights of the
palestinian people
in some way and if so did you convey
that to him in your conversations
one of the reasons why we're able to get
the ceasefire in 11 days
they didn't do what other people have
done i don't talk about what i tell
people in private
i don't talk about what we negotiate in
private oh man what i can assure you
though
is that the last time it took 56 days
and then six months to get a cease fire
i'm praying this ceasefire will hold
i take bibi netanyahu and he gives me
his word i take him at his word he's
never broken his word to me
and but what i've made clear
is that it's essential it's essential
that
the palestinians in on the west bank
be secured that abbas
be recognized as the leader of the
palestinian people which is hamas
is a terrorist organization we recognize
that but that doesn't mean we should not
be in gaza
rebuilding gaza for all those innocent
people who in fact
have been hurt and and have been
collateral damage
including loss of homes and a whole
range of other things
as well as insisting that
israeli citizens whether to be arab or
jew
are treated equally as israeli
citizens and that's what was going on in
in in in jerusalem and so
that has to come to an end and bibi know
the
prime minister knows my views and uh but
the commitment that was given
was immediately kept i from the very
beginning i told him what
our objective was that there's need to
be a ceasefire
and he in fact kept his commitment in a
time frame in which he said he would do
it
thank you and by the way
i wasn't the only one that spoke to we
had i looked down here
every major player on my team from
secretary of defense the secretary of
state
all the way down the line and our
national security were in
constant contact with their counterparts
in israel in egypt and throughout the
middle east
right this was not something that was
just done with a casual conversation
between myself and bibi i have
presumptions to me to say this but mr
president but i think i've got a great
team
and the wristband i spent a lot of time
with el-sisi on the phone and
in in egypt and they've done a
commendable job
of bringing hamas to the table and
getting them to agree
to a ceasefire as well thank you
is that it
you have an awkward dynamic sir a lady
all ladies do not raise their hands
will a lady ask a question please oh do
we not have female journalists from
korea
what is happening
good afternoon from korea herald my name
is indian
wow the korean people are very
curious about vaccines and they're
waiting for the good news
regarding vaccine i understand that
you've had
a lot of discussions with president
biden regarding vaccine and i wonder
whether you have any good news to
deliver to the people of korea
and has there been any meaningful you
may be wondering vaccines
we've got there's millions of facts
everybody's desperate for the vaccines
we have and 40 percent of republicans
don't want them
information
[Music]
you can read the joint statements and
also the remarks
that were issued as press release today
but to emphasize it once again between
the u.s and korea
for vexing cooperation there will be a
comprehensive partnership to be
established between our two nations and
there has been an agreement between our
two sides on that
right the u.s has the ability to develop
vaccines and korean companies have the
capacity to produce
a biomedicine and we are going to
combine those capabilities so that we
can boost the vaccine supply so that we
can
accelerate the rollout of vaccines to
the entire world especially in the
indo-pacific region
for supplying vaccines to that region i
believe that we'll be able to make a
contribution in the regard
and in that process korea
in my opinion will
get some help in uh stabilizing our
vaccine supply
and at the same time for the sake of the
rock u.s alliance
president biden decided to
provide vaccines to the
servicemen in korea as soon as the u.s
is ready
i understand there will be an
announcement to be made by the u.s side
let's prematurely make that we're going
to their
550 000 korean soldier sailors airmen
who work in close contact with american
forces
in korea we'll provide full vaccinations
for all 550 000 of those
korean forces engaging with american
forces on a regular basis
both for their sake as well as the sake
of the american forces
in addition to that we've talked about
the ability to
have vaccines produced with
our working with and this is in the
offing
working with one of the major
vaccine producers in the united states
and
where the korea is incredibly
sophisticated and with the help of that
particular
that that particular company will be
able to make significant numbers of
vaccines
for themselves and lastly it is my hope
and expectation
i cannot commit to it because we don't
know for certain
but we think that over the remainder of
2021 we're going to be able to vaccinate
every american we have enough we have
enough vaccine to vaccinate every
american
period right now and we're going to be
able to do that we'll have to convince a
few
and we're going to continue to get more
people to engage in
seeking the vaccine i don't believe and
never have believed
that there's a large percentage of
americans who will not
take the vaccine and we're doing very
imaginative things as
states are to get people to show up and
have the vaccine
but we believe we believe that between
the second half of 2021 and going in
through 2022
we could produce as many as another
billion doses of vaccine
because it's not just and this is what i
like about this president
he's not just talking about any more
that i'm just talking about the united
states or just
korea he's talking about the
indo-pacific he's talking about the
world
we with advanced capabilities
have an obligation to do everything we
can
to provide for protection of the entire
world i know that is an awfully
awfully awfully ambitious proposal
but i think the nations that have that
capacity are going to be continuing to
work toward getting that done
and so thank you if you're not asking me
like you usually do it's something
interesting
president obama says
that there is footage oh no uh records
of
objects in the skies oh my god an
identified aerial phenomenon
and he says we don't know exactly what
they
are what do you think that it is i would
ask him again
thank you
come on let's go
[Applause]
what are we clapping for i don't even
know
[Applause]
okay
come on come on bud let's go is a pretty
good wrap up for a foreign
for another foreign leader all right
guys they started an hour late but they
got it done
i hope everybody has a great weekend and
don't uh
don't do anything i wouldn't do and
maybe don't even do the some of the
things i would do okay see everybody
next week
you